Imagine an AI assistant drops this
report on your desk. It says support
tickets are up 40% due to a recent user
interface update and advises you to
revert the code and hire more staff
immediately. When a document arrives
perfectly structured, cleanly formatted
and phrased with absolute certainty. The
immediate human instinct is to nod along
and hit approve. But a slick
presentation often does the heavy
lifting that actual evidence should be
doing. We routinely mistake a confident
delivery for a proven fact. This scatter
plot displays a 2025 study of 666
professionals. It shows a measurable
negative correlation between frequent AI
use and critical thinking ability. The
primary driver is users substituting a
highly polished answer for their own
independent evaluation. Algorithms
amplify this vulnerability. They are
programmed to sound certain by default
regardless of whether that certainty is
actually earned by the underlying data.
To survive in a landscape filled with
fluent machines, you need a systematic
mechanism. You have to look underneath a
conclusion's polished surface before you
decide to base real world money and
action upon it. Think of critical
thinking as a dedicated factchecker. It
doesn't write the report and it doesn't
solve the problem. It takes a finished
conclusion and tests the claims holding
it up. This ladder of inference traces a
confident conclusion backwards. At the
top, we have the action taken and the
belief driving it. But climbing down to
the middle rungs, we hit the exact space
where data is assigned meaning and where
assumptions are silently made. Most
costly business decisions do not start
with incorrect raw data. The disaster
usually happens when someone climbs past
an unverified assumption halfway up this
ladder without checking their footing.
In our AI ticket report, the system
noticed the 40% spike and grabbed a
pattern from general experience that UI
changes cause support spikes. It then
assumed that pattern applied to this
specific situation without actually
verifying it. Isolating the exact moment
an observation mutates into an
assumption is the only reliable way to
stop a plausible sounding theory from
triggering an expensive mistake. To test
the stability of that unexamined leap,
we apply a four-part practical filter.
Source, method, currency, and motive.
First, we check the source and method.
We ask exactly where the data originated
and specifically how those measurements
were calculated. This bar chart breaks
down the 40% spike. We separate the
volume metric from the resolution time
calculation. A massive chunk is just a
tagging artifact. Importantly, the
resolution time method ignores how long
tickets sit in the unassigned queue.
This timeline graph introduces the
currency check. We steal man the AI's
theory by asking what else changed in
the business during that exact same
week. We immediately spot a major
pricing change that shipped on the exact
same day as the UI update. Finally, the
motive check. An algorithm doesn't have
a personal agenda, but its authoritative
framing does the same psychological
work. It makes a loose correlation feel
like a settled fact. Applying these four
questions systematically strips away the
polish of a presentation until you are
left with only the verifiable facts.
Running a conclusion through this filter
alters what you do next. It downgrades
an absolute directive to roll back the
software into a mere hypothesis that
needs further testing. The raw data at
the bottom of the ladder was real. The
ticket volume did go up. The AI just
misapplied the assumptions and
conclusions layered on top of it. Once
we account for the pricing change and
that flawed Q measurement we identified,
the actual business bottleneck comes
into focus. It was a triage log jam.
Adding headcount to resolve tickets
wouldn't have helped if the tickets were
stuck in a queue waiting to be assigned.
This breakdown shows the true output of
critical thinking. Your goal is to
produce a definitive judgment of the
information at hand. categorizing the
claims as sound, questionable, or
missing entirely.
Deciding how to fix that triage pipeline
is a creative act. Evaluating the
integrity of the picture you are looking
at is purely critical. In an era
overflowing with infinite, confident
answers, the discipline of critical
thinking gives you the ultimate
professional advantage. It provides the
confidence to know exactly which parts
of a picture will actually hold your
weight.